[Música]
el azúcar está jugando a las escondidas
contigo pensarías que es fácil ganar con
todo el azúcar que hay en refrescos
helados dulces y en las bolsas de azúcar
las personas obtienen la mitad de los
azúcares añadidos de esas bebidas y
golosinas por eso podría parecer que el
azúcar está a simple vista pero la otra
mitad se oculta en los lugares menos
sospechosos por ejemplo el que echa
salsa de espagueti leche de soja y
mantequilla de maní
de hecho encontrarás azúcares añadidos
en tres cuartas partes de los más de
600.000 artículos disponibles en las
tiendas pero como se oculta el azúcar no
la puedes ver en las etiquetas de los
alimentos no es tan fácil al igual que a
tu amigo roberto le pueden decir beto
robbie robe betito o robert el azúcar
añadido tiene muchos alias
y no 5 o 6 156 tenemos jarabe de arroz
integral cebada malteada azúcar moreno
azúcar de florida mascabado y por
supuesto el jarabe de maíz de alta
fructosa a veces llamado azúcar de maíz
incluso los apodos difíciles del azúcar
tienen apodos el extracto de uva de
manzana tienen los mismos efectos en el
cuerpo que sus 55 gemelos azucarados
además cuando varios tipos de azúcares
añadidos se usan en un producto quedan
enterradas en una larga lista de
ingredientes por lo que el contenido de
azúcar puede parecer bien pero sumados
resulta que el azúcar es el ingrediente
principal
actualmente la fed nos sugiere un límite
diario recomendado de azúcar por eso es
difícil saber si estos 65 gramos en una
botella de refresco son poco o mucho
pero la organización mundial de la salud
recomiendan limitar el azúcar a sólo el
5% del total de calorías o unos 25
gramos por día 65 gramos es más del
doble de esa cantidad pero cuál es la
diferencia entre la glucosa y la
fructosa ambos son hidratos de carbono
pero tienen estructuras diferentes y se
comportan de manera muy diferente en
nuestros cuerpos la glucosa puede ser
metabolizada por todos los órganos del
cuerpo la fructosa por otra parte se
metaboliza principalmente en el hígado y
cuando el hígado se sobrecarga de
fructosa el exceso se metaboliza en
grasa
las frutas frescas contienen fructosa
pero es de origen natural y no provoca
sobrecarga porque la fibra de la fruta
ralentiza su absorción el azúcar hace a
las galletas fibrosa si a los dulces
crujientes incluso dora la corteza del
pan es también un gran conservante no se
descompone ni evapora y los alimentos
que la tienen son fáciles de almacenar y
enviar a grandes distancias y tienden a
ser más baratos en realidad podría ser
más fácil enumerar los alimentos donde
no se oculta el azúcar añadido vegetales
huevos carnes pescado frutas y frutos
secos
elegir a agua en vez de refresco jugos y
bebidas deportivas es una gran forma de
evitar el azúcar añadido oculto por lo
menos trata de prestar atención a las
etiquetas para mantener el consumo de
azúcar en un nivel saludable porque en
este juego de las escondidas cada vez
que no encuentras el azúcar añadido
ganas